llega directo américa la revista de
prensa y leo díaz y los buenos días a
rosa pérez más de un buen día para usted
rosa buenos días ángel a cuestas muy
bien muy bien y vamos a comenzar
hablando de una noticia pues por los
derechos humanos todos los presentadores
de tolo news se cubrieron el rostro en
solidaridad con sus compañeras en
afganistán efectivamente no una noticia
con la que podemos empatizar muchísimo
pues ya tú y yo angela recordemos lo que
pasó y es que precisamente en la 7 de
mayo el gobierno talibán el gobierno de
afganistán
decretó la orden de que todas las
mujeres del país debían cubrirse el
rostro en presencia de hombres que no
fueran de su familia básicamente en
público sin embargo las presentadoras de
televisión en un primer momento se
resistieron no a pues a asumir también
ya cubrirse el rostro pues en sus
programas televisivos entre otras cosas
el director de este canal afgano tolo
news dijo que bueno ellos respondieron a
las autoridades talibanas diciendo que
consideraban que presencia de las
mujeres en televisión no era una
presencia física sino virtual y
evidentemente también pues estaban en
contra no de esta imposición de ésta
pues el recorte de libertades de las
mujeres afganas pero digamos un poco
entrando en la argumentación de los
talibanes argumentaba en esto pero sin
embargo pues el ministerio por la
propagación de la virtud dio un
ultimátum a todas las periodistas y
presentadoras afganas diciendo que ayer
domingo debían ya cubrirse el rostro al
aparecer en pantalla por lo que como
vemos en esta imagen finalmente todo el
equipo de esta cadena tolo news decidió
cubrirse el rostro pues en este caso con
una mascarilla en una solidaridad con
sus compañeras no y de hecho pues en
otra pieza recogida por la agencia efe
una presidenta dora vaciedad yo ya del
canal a ryan otro canal dijo el islam no
es una religión pues que imponga nada a
los hombres ya las mujeres nos
recordemos esta es una decisión del
gobierno fundamentalista de afganistán
particularmente de este órgano el
ministerio de la propagación de la
virtud y la prevención del vicio que fue
reinstaurado con la llegada de los
talibanes al poder
pues el pasado agosto de 2021 y que pues
muy simbólicamente instalaron este
ministerio en el extinto ministerio pues
de la mujer
y era algo que veníamos diciendo que
veníamos advirtiendo algo que veíamos
venir en una interpretación
absolutamente radical de la ley islámica
pero bueno vamos a cambiar de tema vamos
a hablar de mi país este fin de semana
es bien importante para los colombianos
ya está todo listo para las elecciones
presidenciales
exactamente angela y así lo recoge el
tiempo en este artículo que lo titula a
sí mismo no que el gobierno pues ella ay
el país ya está preparado para estas
elecciones históricas que empiezan el
próximo domingo 29 con una primera ronda
y de hecho tal y como señala este texto
ya ha empezado el voto en el exterior
particularmente en nueva zelanda que es
uno de los 67 países del mundo donde
cerca de un millón de colombianos
van a votar fuera de su propio país por
otro lado también este artículo señala
que el actual presidente e iván duque
negó las palabras de la líder de
izquierda gustavo petro en las que este
fin de semana a través de sus redes
sociales dijo que potencialmente estaba
preparándose una suspensión de las
elecciones recordemos dijo que esto pues
era algo que se anunciaría mañana sin
embargo como decimos no el actual
presidente ha desmentido pues estas
declaraciones vamos a ver lo que acaba
pasando por otro lado finalmente este
artículo también repasa algunos de los
actos de cierre de campaña que tuvieron
lugar ayer nos fijamos en el del
izquierdista gustavo petro y también
pues en el de su contrincante pues fico
gutiérrez federico gutiérrez de derechas
no por un lado gustavo petro dijo ayer
en la plaza bolívar a tiene el centro de
bogotá este es un gobierno que de ser
elegido será para todos y para todas
trataremos de acabar con el odio
político que ha crecido en la sociedad
colombiana y es que el precisamente no
es diana de una campaña de acoso y
derribo
pues por parte de la derecha sobre todo
y por otro lado fico gutiérrez el
derechista del equipo por colombia y
argumentó a quienes representan
proyectos políticos populistas y
autoritarios refiriéndose claramente a
petro no les vamos a entregar colombia
están desesperados porque les vamos a
ganar una afirmación que de momento no
está pues respaldada por las encuestas
que dan a petro más de 10 puntos no de
victoria por delante de fico gutiérrez
pero recordemos estaría entre un 41 y 42
por ciento de la intención de voto
mientras que fico gutiérrez recoge de
momento 100 cerca del 25 por ciento de
los apoyos o sea que todo pintó de que
vamos para una segunda vuelta rosa de
esto vamos a hablar más adelante con el
invitado del día y rápidamente un último
titular moscú times tenemos que
comprarlo todos soldados rusos infra
equipados en la guerra de ucrania esto
es distintos soldados del ejército ruso
declaran anónimamente ante el equipo de
investigación de este medio del moscú
times que tienen que comprar de su
propio bolsillo calzado chaleco
antibalas a de vendas y torniquetes
cuando dirigen a ucraniano a luchar del
lado de moscú solamente citamos una de
las declaraciones que hay en este
artículo una fuente anónima que dice ni
siquiera estoy hablando de chalecos
antibalas o cascos modernos no hay ropa
de abrigo falta comida y no hay
botiquines de primeros auxilios todo el
equipamiento con el que luchamos en
ucrania apesta a naftalina y las armas
se atascan gracias por resaltar los
rosas atrocidades de los que
infortunadamente tenemos que seguir
hablando en france24 y ahora como le
venía diciendo pues vamos con el
invitado del día